ultron one big planet full of robots
or maybe thanos does rewrite the
universe
after end game like he was trying to do
and he doesn't get wiped out so we see
what that world looks like
the events of one division are gonna set
up scarlet witch as
a villain the big bad of this is
dr doom
welcome back to new rockstars this is
rogue theory i'm eric boss filling in
again for phil molina he'll be back soon
trust me today folks we are maddeningly
multiplying multiverses like some real
maniacs going rogue remotely today
are sam basher welcome back
thank you for having me i dressed up for
the occasion i'm happy to be here
oh so see we're already wearing that
those are his pajamas also with us today
marina mastros
hi hi and our good friend off-screen
producer zach cuddleston
thank you in honor of you eric i'm
cracking open a bang energy drink little
peach mango
for you i didn't know we were
celebrating
or selling anything at the moment
okay let's talk about doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness folks you may
have seen last week it just got delayed
again to march 2022
which is weird it's a month after thor 4
which is staying put
actually moved a week earlier in
february 2022 it sounds like marvel just
wants to give themselves as much time as
possible to figure out
the exact concept and look and texture
of the multiverse they don't want to
screw it up
and they actually announced they're
going to bring in sam raimi's long time
production designer robert stromberg
bringing in the big guns now we have
seen some unused art and footage
including
doctor strange in an alternate blue cape
and wearing um
iron man's armor and an infinity war set
photo that just came out
and recently we learned that
disneyland's avengers campus is actually
going to feature doctor strange
explaining the multiverse it sounds like
the most it's a very big deal they want
to give themselves all the time in the
world to figure it out so i want you
guys
to pitch me your exact theory for what
the multiverse of madness
is exactly like what is doctor strange's
big threat in the sequel how's he gonna
go about trying to handle it but really
why is the multiverse so
mad may i go for it all right so uh
buckle up because this is a wild ride
we're going through the multiverse
and it's filled with madness first off i
think we've heard this with a couple
theories now that after you're getting
so many
snaps happening in one universe you're
gonna have ramifications
it's just that's basic math we were
taught that in elementary school
my pitch is that we go like we saw
dormammu
a cosmic universe ending threat in the
first doctor strange let's keep the ball
rolling i know baron mordo was like
teased
but let's go big classic doctor strange
villain showed up in
doctor strange strange adventures uh
number five schuma gorath big cthulhu
like
giant eye monster coming to eat your
world
hide your kids hide your wife reference
really dated reference
good i think that's good thank you all
right so he's coming he's coming to
gobble up dimensions
things are bad uh and we know that
since he's aiming to come to our
dimension he's probably been to other
dimensions before doctor strange
he's got cosmic awareness he's got a
sense that something's afoot something's
bad
so he's gonna need help balancing
reality or having the help of someone
who has control over reality and that's
kind of
usually how we view scarlet witch's
powers that she has
uh domain over probability and she's
able to kind of manipulate that
and manipulate that in the comics and i
would like to see more of that
in this movie as well as her tapping
more into her magical side
she is a witch we've never seen her do
that she just like picked rocks up and
to hypnotize people so i think that
she's going to be enlisted by doctor
strange to traverse the multiverse to
find a way to stop schumachoraz from
coming
to our dimension and i think that since
with the infinity stones are no longer
being used and her powers were activated
by the stones she will be like his
compass or guide through the multiverse
or like the power that he taps into to
use it because he doesn't have the time
stone anymore it doesn't have any of
those tools
um and i think because he also asked us
to kind of pitch like
what it would look like i think it'd be
a merger between
the sparkle show with the portals and
them going through it as well as
like her red energy so kind of uh the
doorway opens via his sparkle show but
she's more of like a balancing act like
you know she also uses her ability like
i said with um kind of manipulating
people's minds bringing out their worst
nightmares
uh maybe with that ability she's also
able to kind of weed through all the
craziness and the madness that is the
multiverse um
and and kind of just gives them clarity
so they're able to visit different
universes and then
that's how we start seeing the blue
suited doctor strange
we're getting real creative here with
our universes
we start seeing him in the mark 50 uh
iron man armor because why not it's
going to look cool it's always cool when
you get magic and tech mixing together
you could see disneyland also i always
love the whole thing when we see like
cartoon universe or a muppet universe
or like star wars universe why not go
big
why not hey go have some fun here um and
also
i love when we get to go to like bad
news bears universes like things went
just totally totally bad like we see
ultron exactly bad news
rally a team of baseball players
together
to beat the yankees we're all familiar
that's exactly
that's what we want from these movies
but i'm thinking like ultron one
big planet full of robots nobody wants
that or
maybe thanos does rewrite the universe
after
end game like he was trying to do and he
doesn't get wiped out so we see what
that world looks like
anyways just pitching that nightmare
dimensions and you see
each dimension to see if like red skull
won and
if uh yeah like each uh nightmare flavor
is great
like i i want to see that and maybe
bring dormammu back if we're going
through the multiverse
we saw the multiverse doctor strange one
he was a big feature in it he's like a
roadside attraction we're going to have
to go check in on him and see how it's
going
with uh kaiselius that's the that's what
mads michael said
that's what he his role was wasted on
yeah it was kaiselius
um but but the big thing i want to see
in this is
wanda utilizing magic specifically we
know that she's a powerhouse we know
that she can
uh do move mountains with her brain
and but i want to see her like start
casting spells i want to see them go up
against like
uh interdimensional threats or
extraterrestrial threats and she
they're able to work together and kind
of expand upon the magical elements of
the mcu beyond just like mandela flowers
on shields or like lay
or like little spears flying out you
know i want to see it get really
creative in this movie
yeah i agree sam that sounds like a
fantastic theory
and i love the idea of uh mixing dr
strange's magic with wanda's magic in a
way that seems like mutually compatible
with each other so that all
magic seems like clear that we know when
magic's being used in the mcu
and uh the idea that like uh her you
know
sorcery will be an internal battle and
one division
turning into this external battle in uh
doctor streams of multiverse madness
sounds like a very interesting evolution
for her character and yeah
any way we can bring back these mcu
villains in ways that justify maybe
their missteps in the past
and the way they've been displayed is
good on in my book and for that you get
two rogies sparkle bucks that are
effects in your way
right oh my goodness oh they i get my
fax machines on the floor excuse me
oh well this is sweet you sent me a
luigi
and i guess you got to tell me what to
do
uh you got to tell me what the theme is
with this one i got a the the vinyl of
bohemian rhapsody
he says is this a favorite of yours i
appreciate it
oh and how thematically appropriate is
this the real life
or is it just fantasy we don't know
what's
really relevant very good i give
you a sparkle a buck a stanley nickel
a shrimp oh sam you don't
you have flash uh speed force powers you
don't know what that did to me
[Laughter]
i'll never recover okay so who's next
with this dr strange multiverse madness
theory
i actually got help with this theory um
from my friend frank who has been on the
show before you guys might remember
frank marie yeah yeah right uh at happy
go jackie if you wanna
uh thank him on twitter it would be like
you supplied marina theory but i did
tweak it a little bit
um so uh basically the plot
of doctor strange two is that wanda has
her show right
and she is
discovering her powers and she realizes
that they're
too much and she needs help controlling
them so she
beginning of doctor strange boom wanda
shows up going hey i need your help
she's tapped into these powers that
she's not sure how to handle
and that's how things start rolling but
doctor strange is dealing with the
ramifications of everything that
happened in endgame
and which is a lot i mean he went
through and saw you know 14 million
or billion whatever uh universes and
possibilities and timelines
so he's a little off his game sure
yep and the big bad of this is
doctor doom because he needs so doctor
strange doesn't know that dr doom is bad
yet
he's just a scientist who also uses
magic just like him
so he goes to him for help because he's
tired he's exhausted
he just like and also he's humbled right
by this point
so he's going to him genuinely for help
um with wanda and dr doom
is like yeah cool like i'll help you
figure out like the multiverse and i'll
help you figure out her powers
but the reason that he's actually doing
it is to bring back
his mother from mephisto oh
interesting so mephisto has his mother
uh in hell or wherever you want to call
it
and uh because he's a demon and so
dr doom is telling them that he's on
their side they think he's a good
character
but really he's doing it for his own
reasons so the only way to stop mephisto
and doctor doom and get control of
everything is to release a huge amount
of power and only wanda has that power
but she's not in control of it yet so
she starts just releasing her power to
to stop this demon and this doctor
and this villain and we're going through
her mind she's
controlling everything and it's just
boom boom boom boom boom switching
switching and it's totally out of
control
and the only way the doctor strange can
stop her
she's not meaning to be bad but she's
out of control
is by putting her in her own dimension
in her
own entire universe in this multiverse
so he locks her in her own thing
gets control of everything he keeps her
uh in control until she calms down or
whatever
puts the villains in their place movie
ends great
post-credits scene okay
because doctor strange broke this rule
he's [ __ ] up this universe somehow
there's a crack and that's how we see
the fantastic four come into our
universe
through this crack that doctor strange
has created because they were off in
this other universe and then
cut to black and everyone's like we need
the next movie ah
oh and also for the disneyland thing
there's more
sorry um in this movie and doctor
strange too when they're going
cutting through all these uh universes
one of them is just disneyland
oh perfect land in disneyland and he's
like and then
when you go to actual disneyland uh
where he shows up to like
host the little like tour or whatever is
where they landed in the actual movie
oh i love that like that but they're
just like eating churros or whatever
yeah
yes please i love this and i love the
idea of uh
dr doom uh tying into the story
uh because yeah it seems like this is a
natural entry point for
victor von doom and the idea that he
could be like this kind of kingpin
figure who's scanning the multiverse
trying to find one
where his loved one is still alive or
still
safe so like it gives him like a
sympathetic drive
to uh but also like you can understand
why he's trying to exploit this mission
for his own personal needs he's not a
monster yet
but he will be by the end of the movie
we'll see how he gets there in person
very nice so marina for your theory i'm
going to award you
one sparkle rogee buck wow
turned into a highlighter whoa whoa
see on your end the sparkle books
transform into whatever your heart
desires
which marina has some um paperwork she's
got to do i guess yeah
zack my theory is based on the mcu phase
four timeline
the events of wan division maybe leaking
through loki and some of the other mcu
movies that come before it
are going to set up scarlet witch as a
villain
okay in the one division series we see
her brilliant powerful mind kind of
break right
maybe some shades of the house of m
storyline for comics
who knows maybe we even get like kind of
a false resolution and by the end of
that limited series
oh she's gone nuts but they're able to
rein her back in and maybe
you know the ghost division calms her
down or something like that
maybe she's even put into some kind of
like uh
stealing off of um marina's theory there
maybe she even kind of goes off
puts herself into her like little coma
multiverse or whatever
right okay um and she kind of awakens
in multiverse of madness and this is
boom it's doctor strange
versus scar wow
wow and so i think like doctor strange
is going to be tasked with
like trying to stop scarlet witch on
whatever kind of
insane path maybe she's being
manipulated by like
some very dark forces that realize how
powerful she is and that's only making
her worse
right doctor strange has to like hop
through multiverses to
try to get some kind of mcguffin or
chase her down or stop all the damage
she's doing
um and and and i like i i'm
uh stealing this a little bit from
previous theories too like you mentioned
like what does this look like
i think like doctor strange keeps
opening his portals
and you know scarlet witch keeps doing
her bewitched you know nose wiggle or
whatever
right and like those two visual motifs
kind of collide right and so like the
second you know doctor strange has
opened up a portal and walked into a new
multiverse
boom you know something happens and the
whole thing turns black and white
or something like that right or like you
know which is
transported and then you know uh in
walks
doctor strange and they're kind of
chasing each other using these visual
motifs
because i think like nobody can use that
kind of almost cartoonish
visual visuals better than sam raimi my
second favorite sam
um and so uh uh sam wilson of course big
my
first yeah uh i figured
sam you you've made the top 10 samsung
um
yeah and so i think like he's able to
use that
you know we get i'm seeing the whole
movie will be like this but
you know we're gonna get just an awesome
10 minute montage kind of like
marina and sam have hinted out of just
like going through wacky
crazy it can even be like those old
school like marx brothers bits with the
you know a bunch of doors in the hallway
and people coming in and out of the
doors
but it's multiverses you know and
they're chasing each other and
somebody's coming in the wrong way and
all this kind of stuff
um i think that's what it's going to be
like i also wonder
something none of us have touched on
kevin feige hinted that this movie is
going to be an opportunity to introduce
darker elements into the mcu
like a blade you know dracula ghost
rider that kind of stuff
and none of our theories are really
hitting on that i think we might be
missing out on something
i just don't know how you balance like
you know though blade is dealing with
supernatural stuff
he's like a ground level dude he's not
like traveling in space or through
multiple
dimensions for the most part he's like
you know stabbing vampires and sewers
and stuff like that
so i don't know how you combine these
worlds i do think sam raimi will figure
out a way and it might not be
to like a post-credit scene we're just
like after we've gone all over the
galaxy and all through the multiverses
you know dr strange is just like getting
out of a cab in new york city and like
up from the sewer grate
you know peek some like red vampire eyes
or something like that i
i don't know how it's gonna work but
there will be a little bit of
that kind of ghost and goblin spice in
this movie too
oh my god i just got so excited by that
idea oh my god
i need blade yeah what if he was like a
ghostbuster like what's dr strange been
doing in between he's
been like saving the universe like no
he's got like he like gets werewolves
out of like basements or whatever like
he's trying
to tell yeah different dracula's out
like you could
marvel's got plenty of those characters
he like fights frankenstein's
you guys get it yeah absolutely
zach for reminding us that blade is
coming in this universe
and for recognizing that uh scarlet
witch is totally set up to be a villain
if you consider
uh wanda vision being an adaptation of
house of m in which she's an accidental
village doesn't realize her what her
psionic powers are doing
and this being like a vengeful spirit
who's mad that she doesn't have her kids
anymore or her love vision
that yes she would be a freaking villain
and it would require the sorcerer's
supreme to take her down for those two
points you get two rookies my friend
those transform into a birthday cake
bash
energy drink and a bunch of vanilla
energy drinks you know i love that
flavor black cherry vanilla and bang
before okay everybody give me back your
theories in a tweet okay so yeah a tweet
version of mine
is schuma gorath's invading earth
doctor strange and scarlet witch team up
to explore the multiverse
for uh perfect pest control to take out
a
cthulhu monster i love it
what that's going to take like an
episode of reply all to like break down
so what are these different elements
okay i got it
love it our favorite witch
our least favorite villain doctor
strange
to multiverse of badness
[Laughter]
boom you're looking for that
wanda and strange like whoa
[Music]
against victor von doom and mephisto for
doom's mom's soul
is that um meant to have a musical
melody to it
it sounds like someone uh trying to read
along the lyrics in their church hymnal
but they don't know the melody of the
song like so
no they're off-key
yay all right folks every week we play a
game of rogue theory with our patrons on
the new rockstars discord server
this week we had three selected patrons
pitch their plot for the upcoming venom
two film
the therapy carnage and uh our discord
users kachiti and aj7787 both had
really really great theories but the
winner was brim brim's theory had a lot
of elements from the 90s comics were
under maximum carnage
while also crossing over with morbius
and ant-man some other
sony spider-verse characters uh
basically the idea was like
they brought in matt gargan to um
let out a pulse to cause an earthquake
in san francisco and that earthquake
allows uh carnage to escape from san
quentin
he brings in shriek like in the maximum
carnage story line there's a
ending that ties in the x-con van uh
and then a post-credits scene that
involves um
eddie gave an email from like at jj at
uh dailybugle.net asking him for a job
some a lot of great fan service in world
building here but
what do you guys think about this idea i
i
love a good like why not in your fan
theory plot
ignore like copyright ownership
just include the things you want don't
worry about who owns what rights
you know because within a couple years
disney's going to own everything anyway
oh amen couple months
buy me out please really
okay uh well let's move on to our second
topic um
we're gonna talk about drafting our
avengers so you may have seen this this
week entertainment weekly made some wave
on twitter
when they uh put out a list of all the
mcu characters with dollar values
attached to them
and then challenged all of us to draft
our own avengers
using a total of 15 probably inspired by
the nfl draft which is also happening at
the same time
uh you know sports also happen in our
universe
news to me uh lots of people are arguing
over the values assigned to the heroes
to begin with they're like
are they really worth three dollars
that's not necessarily fair uh but uh we
can get into that
i want to know from you guys go rogue
tell me uh what would your
15 avengers draft look like
i mean mine's basically god tier if i
may just kick it off here
uh there's like no way anyone's gonna
beat this team thanos yeah
more like uh
i had a full a little tiny baby stroke
there that was
there we go nailed it landed the plane
uh inverted the bird landed the plane
uh so first up uh easy just uh and you
guys would understand that this makes
sense for four dollars
ant-man because he not only is regular
size but he could be small
and big did you see how he was just
stomping on whales during that fight
at the end of event game all right nice
try yeah no one's going to beat that
next groot because he could uh he can
get
we haven't gotten here yet but we know
he's going to become like super sized
right he was really tiny he was adult
size and there's no way we're not going
to get like massive sequoia-like
giant groot stomping on emma effers so
i'm really excited about that
next you had to do scarlet witch we were
talking about her before she warps
reality
i think that's uh that makes sense
self-explanatory for one dollar
vision i get that he might not be
everybody's favorite but like
i i understand and he's kind of dead now
but we don't know what that means
but like he phases through walls he's
super strong he flies
he's got a laser in his head for some
inexplicable reason
and uh and his voice by paul bettany so
he's already got like the british tom
like tomba in his voice the accent um
and to finish out the team
we got thor i'd rather have fat thor
chubby thor
thick thor uh just because he's i i i
personally enjoyed him more now he's got
an axe instead of just a regular old
boring hammer that you can't even cut
stuff with
so you've got god tier thor literal king
of asgard now you got vision
for one goddang dollar
i wanted to actually get like 15 visions
and then no one's going to beat me
but i guess we're not going to do that
it's just a bargain it's just a bargain
uh scarlet witch makes sense teaming up
ant-man because you want to have the
biggest guys you can possibly have on
your team the biggest they are
the the harder they fall is what the
saying is but you get what i'm saying
uh and then group because i want to see
him like i want to see like adult size
groot again i want to see baby size
groot again
sometimes in comics he can like like cut
off his arm and it becomes a little baby
groot and that runs off so it's like a
little like drone
so you can have like a bunch of those
there's like a lot of elements here that
gets really it gets really creative when
you get into the fighting scenarios and
that's what i'm excited to see also just
like
i mean you guys can go but like that's
like the perfect roster so
and also a steal sam for recognizing
groot
and ant-man's true potential these guys
are too overlooked in the mcu in my
opinion and if you saw that in-game
final battle those guys were
wrecking [ __ ] you're totally right but i
would give you another one if you didn't
include vision because
um you know my feelings of vision uh you
get one rogie buck for your draft picks
i appreciate it okay sorry fax machine
is down here it's coming out
oh wow you splurged for this one
is this a nintendo switch that's sweet
and animal crossing new horizon with a
whole island set up thank you so much
that was very sweet for you to do all
that work
it was your own heart it was in you the
whole time god of thunder
different universe because you're flash
not that whatever uh who's next with
their draft picks
okay i'll go next and i i had a lot of
different routes i could have gone here
you know i'm a
a true moneyball uh avengers drafter
okay i'm looking
for value all right who bats the most
rbis
that's right that's right and so i was
like oh you know yeah obviously
vision is a steal i think scarlet witch
is is undervalued
for some reason happy is cost
two dollars he's a boxer
like happy who literally just drives and
like runs away from explosions
and as we saw in iron man uh three makes
terrible management decisions sometimes
but um so what i ended up settling on
is like a new version of the classic
lineup right so instead of cap we do
bucky
only cost one dollar instead of um iron
man we do war machine
also one dollar right instead of hulk i
went drax
only because he's another green guy he's
strong
you know he's kind of like his brain
works at a different level than
everybody else he's not bringing what
smart hulk is bringing but you know he's
still like
he's shirtless he's bringing that to the
party um
instead of black widow i just stretch a
little bit here but falcon
you know fellow military spy type person
who's also not
physically enhanced except for with
weapons and stuff like that so
and then um your favorite eric instead
of thor
i went vision only because they're both
like kind of godlike
you know they've got lightning or laser
powers
vision only costs a dollar so i've
replaced the original five avengers
and i've only spent six dollars and that
remaining nine dollars
i'm going to invest okay and then maybe
by
phase five or phase six of the mcu you
know i might have upwards of
12 he's gonna invest it you're gonna
save
that's right you know watch something
watch it grow
a lot of uh a lot of these smaller
franchises want to spend all their
budget on draft picks so sometimes
there's other ways to spend that money
yeah you know put some new seats in the
stadium if you're running the
jacksonville jaguars you can build some
swimming pools
that's right brought us back to the
break shotgun thanks buddy
plus as you know if tommy bechtel were
here he could fill us in on
how the buffalo bills did in the draft
but uh you know
one thing is yeah you don't want to use
all your money in the draft because you
got to save that money for free agents
and i got a feeling
there's going to be some good mcu free
agents coming down the pipeline
a wolverine a reader yeah
yeah the best is yet to come zach uh and
you would probably get um
maybe three rogies but because you
specifically didn't learn the lesson
what i just told sam
this [ __ ] is priced at one dollar for a
reason not interested
if you get one rogey book my friend just
one though
you said evil's got three and you
knocked it down too he would have had
three but he specifically did listen
i told you sam he had a chance to make a
change
also worth worth pointing out happy
hogan's on here and captain marvel
is nowhere to be seen on this whole list
yeah
it's a bit crazy yeah people just like
gabriel
i think i think somebody like somebody
tweeted that and somebody responded like
oh cause
captain marvel would have been 16 by
yourself or something like that
sure i don't know i think it's more uh
an oversight
but um sorry i i didn't want to skip
over it eric that that buck turned into
a cotton candy bang
all right uh marina what is your draft
pick okay great
um first of all i learned my lesson a
long time ago and vision is nowhere
near my life and for that you get one
rogie off the bat
oh my god
okay and also uh my lineup is all women
and people of color so i'm starting off
with of course
scarlet witch uh for two dollars which
is just a steal and also she
is insanely powerful uh and i don't even
think that we've seen
the limits of her power yet so obviously
i want her i want gamora who is
uh per thanos's words the fiercest woman
in the galaxy
and uh black panther of course um
who costs four dollars but is well worth
it
yeah and uh wasp because
she can do everything ant-man can do but
she has better judgment
and she can fly judgment to just put
wings on your suit
yeah and she can fly and a cleaner
criminal record too
yeah she's literally better in every way
uh and i also have nebula for two
who also is a steal it too she's like
such a warrior
very smart and also uh now has a moral
compass
and then war machine who is basically
iron man because he has iron man suit
and he's been practicing long enough so
that he can really
use it to its full potential because the
only thing that was holding him back
before was he had just landed in the
thing
but now he has experience so this is
like
straight up the best of every possible
angle so
i'm ready for my rookies my glitter uh
what are you calling them sparkle sheets
i the name changes every time
marina that lineup sounds great you know
and there's like
each one of the people i would say earn
their spot there like the
challenge the king of like the best
nation on earth
like war machine the poor guy when
everyone's been announcing these
phase four lineups people are like i
guess don cheadle doesn't have work i
hope he invested his money well
because this guy's like been awesome and
he doesn't have a specific movie
uh ready for him hopefully he shows up
in like captain marvel 2 or something
like that
uh but you get an additional rogie for
that lineup because uh yeah i would
definitely go see that movie
great it turned into a little pride flag
i also like marina people of color takes
on new meaning when there are green
and blue characters
i almost think for that reason
but he's extremely racist and sexist
don't translate what he is saying yeah a
terrible person yes
um all right give me back your uh drafts
with a tweet i guess you could just name
your picks or just sum it up in your
theme
um save your money buy cheap avengers
hashtag
great uh women and poc for me
all right great vision is little king
emoji
i'm understanding the game now at my
rage
no one gets an extra rogi from your
tweets no one does
uh but folks it is now time for rogue
questions we're surfing
i don't know what we're doing okay real
question number one
end game writers marcus mcfeely covered
up for a plot hole and a watch along by
saying that the gauntlet thanos puts on
at the end of the age of ultron and
post-credits scene
was a practice gauntlet for the one that
he had to eventually wear
in infinity war and end game what is a
good reason for someone
to have a practice gauntlet you know i
don't know about you guys but
when i first learned to snap i did it
with these two fingers
can anybody uh so maybe like thanos you
know he's an alien
he grew up somewhere else that's true
yeah
i snapped his index fingers zach so
maybe he had to practice
he he didn't know how to do this snap
either
zach i can't believe that's true that's
i guess it works but it
i don't know zack's gonna have earlier
carpal tunnel than the rest of us
if somebody was messing with you as a
kid they were like this is how you snap
zach and you were like okay no zach i'm
in your corner i snapped that way i
snapped with all the fingers i didn't
snap with all the fingers i didn't have
a lot of talents as a kid i can't play
instruments
i'm not good at running i can't do uh
backflips
so i figured out how to snap all my
fingers wait sam did someone tell you
that being able to do a backflip is
something that everyone should know
every cool kid did you watch any disney
channel original movies
they were all doing backflips that's
right brink was doing constant backflips
sam was just bullied by the navarro
cheerleaders growing up yeah
ruthless okay so i mean this is easy
right like i mean
i don't know about you guys but when i
was a kid and i was given a nice piece
of clothing like dress shoes like a pair
of slacks
or like a button-up shirt like i just
think anything you'd wear to a funeral
um but it was uh i my parents would be
like
don't get anything on it don't scuff
them up
and then i'd still go out and play
soccer and i get like get like
smuts or i'd scuff up my shoes and then
like my
my parents would be furious now i'm just
guessing this is a classic scenario he
put on a glove
he went out and he started playing like
playstation or he was playing ball with
his boys
and he just scuffed it up and it didn't
look good and we know
when it comes to thanos it's all about
presentation he knows his speeches
he knows his looks it's always been big
gold tees of some sort
and you think he's gonna go into a
battle and have it all be all like
scuffed up mm-hmm
no he's gonna if he's gonna murder
a bunch of people he's gonna look good
doing it i love the idea of thanos like
checking himself out in a mirror
with his glove and being like oh this
won't do
yeah glad i got another one yeah that's
a thanos we know
and also maybe the eternals came in you
know like they shamed him a little bit
they're like you
ruined this we got church on sunday yeah
uh mine is simple he just had to figure
out if he could fit it into his purse
yes thanos's little-known purse
yeah that's right and then yeah
yeah it's the infinity clutch yeah
that's great
dang it i'm not gonna make that joke uh
number two
uh disney announced ryza skywalker will
hit disney plus
in time for star wars on may the 4th
how will you watch it differently at
home than you would in the theater
uh i'm i'm gonna watch it on mute
but with the closed captions on so that
i can scream whenever i want
where's rose where is she
and then that's it yeah and then your
neighbors will think like oh
we're watching uh titanic
[Laughter]
where's rose i'm gonna i'm gonna watch
it the exact same way i watched in the
theater
no pants
has your court date come up yet zach
delayed due to corona
everything's been delayed uh
i'm gonna watch it uh with fresh eyes
because i still have not seen that bad
boy it just slipped right by me
i was seeing i know hey i'll take the
heat
i've seen cats twice and i've seen rise
of skywalker a total of goose egg
and i've made a i've made good decisions
those are good decisions
you know what if you've seen cats twice
you can do whatever you want that's
right
free power god mode yeah god bless you
god bless you all right on to our third
one michael jackson's nephew did an
interview this week where he repeated a
story that stan lee had mentioned years
ago
that in the mid 90s michael jackson was
in talks to buy marvel
with the specific motivation being that
he wanted to play spider-man in a movie
what oh musician would have been great
to see as an mcu character
and can you give it to me in the form of
an impression of that actor
singing in character um okay
it's not singing but this is um
a scene it's cardi b
as shuri trying to remove the mind stone
from vision
okay okay yo leave me
alone i'm trying to do like science and
[ __ ] i'm trying to do like
let me do this neurons okay i'm gonna
move the neurons but you all up in my
ass hold on i'm trying to do like in
science
all right lovely lovely i
bleep it
who's next i was real nervous about this
one just because impressions and singing
are not my strong suit but
i will be performing today um
captain marvel as billy eilish
where are you going i'm just gonna go
kill thanos
i can't do more for everyone's sake but
you get the gist
that's very funny also just putting it
out there
i think she'd be a good gwen stacy if
they wanted to do spider going in real
life because she's got the hair i think
it'd be good just putting it out there
yeah she has a tough energy too like you
could believe her kicking some butt
okay mine is gonna be uh keeping the
theme here
of uh female uh musicians and this is
gonna be in a rebooted
gender swapped fantastic four miss
lauren hill
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's
[Laughter]
what are our final scores of rogueis out
there uh
i have two i think i've got three paying
energy drinks which is like an afternoon
for air advice
i i have the i got a nintendo switch
bohemian rhapsody vinyl and a luigi hat
oh well sam of with that
asmr that's going to give me something
later to infinity clutch i give you
hey another sparkle rogue buck
that makes you today's winner thank you
i mean should i show what it came
through yes through the fax
an open can of seltzer
thank you and it's still cold i love how
sam i think for the most part has
had used his fingers to cover up certain
logos
thank you uh well sam as the winner
today's episode
you are rewarded a a wish that you get
to bequeath
upon uh your other two uh co-hosts so
uh what would you like them to do for
you today
all right so as a group i would like all
of us i'll participate too we're all in
this boat together
just like this quarantine i want to sing
all of us the office theme song now
those are just beats and tones and
whatnot
i just want to do it all together here
i'll do it first and then we can just
join in whenever you want yeah i love it
okay okay i'm gonna remember it
five six seven eight band
then
did
what is happening on zack's camera sorry
my my camera was falling down but i'm
still shooting even though my zoom is
now covered up
okay okay exactly editor john i
apologize
yeah here's an ending if john wants it
perfect nailed it great well that is it
for this episode of rogue theory thanks
again to all of our guests
uh sam basher our winner of today
uh marina mastros thank you for joining
us as well
and of course off-screen producer zach
huddleston you guys are all
cherished in my heart and it's so great
to see your faces
uh don't forget to subscribe to rogue
theory podcast feed and stay tuned for
the youtube channel for this
and other shows follow me at eavos and
follow us on twitter and instagram
new rockstars uh thank you for joining
us see you next week bye
[Music]
you